Так, на пальцях, Олексій Канарський перераховує,
скільки часу чекає на грошову допомогу від держави.
Він один з 74 звільнених цієї зими полонених.
Як і решті, уряд обіцяв йому 100 тисяч гривень компенсації.
Час іде, а грошей так і немає.
Я на них, якщо чесно, не розраховую. Мені б паспорт.
Я може, гроші як небудь спробую сам підзбирати трохи
і там якось назбираю трохи.
Обіцянку отримати гроші від держави
він почув наступного ж дня після звільнення.
Її зробив міністр соціальної політики Андрій Рева.
Однак лише через два з половиною місяці
уряд ухвалив відповідну постанову.
За нею звільнені мали звернутися
до місцевих служб соціальної допомоги,
написати заяву про бажання отримати кошти
та надати документ, що посвідчує особу.
На цю процедуру виділено півроку.
Термін закінчується 27 червня.
Ми не можемо персонально, як міністерство,
збирати заяви від цих осіб.
Ці особи вони роз'їхались по всій Україні.
ручніше, щоб особи не їхали до Києва, щоб подати заяву,
а їхали або йшли до місцевого органу соціального захисту.
Далі місцеві органи соціального захисту звертаються назад
до Міністерства окупованих територій.
Аби ті звірили прізвища зі списком СБУ
і  нарешті надали розпорядження на виділення коштів.
Лише після цього гроші спускаються в регіони,
і вже місцева влада має їх перекинути на рахунки звільнених полонених.
Така заплутана та довга схема
обурює звільненого Володимира Фомічова.
Філософія є в тому, що коли людина звільняється,
ця допомога їй потрібна відразу.
Щоб вирішувати свої побутові питання, які виникають.
Вже 6 місяців пройшло з мого повернення з полону,
Але все одно є питання, які залишаються. Навіть працевлаштування...
Володимиру пощастило, в Києві на нього чекали друзі.
А ось Олексію допомоги не було від кого отримати.
Мобільний телефон, навушники, зарядка.
Це всі речі, які він мав при собі,  коли в окупованому Шахтарську
його затримали проросійські бойовики.
Коли через три роки звільнили - не мав і цього.
Нині він і досі не отримав паспорт,
хоча, за його словами, до міграційної служби звернувся ще в лютому.
Він чи не єдиний, хто ще не написав заяву на отримання 100 тисяч,
бо, каже, у бюрократичних питаннях не розбирається
і не знає, куди і які документи подавати.
Від нас дізнається, що треба їхати за місцем нинішньої реєстрації.
Та без паспорта - боїться.
Я туди один раз їздив,
то назад, коли приїхав, мене почали обшукувати.
Поліція. Може, я там в потязі автомат везу чи гранату,
можливо, я якийсь зрадник.
Володимир Фомічов вважає, що усі бюрократичні процедури
можна було провести ще в перший місяць,
коли всі звільнені перебували у лікарні Феофанія.
Каже, СБУ, наприклад, створили мобільні групи
й одразу в лікарні надали усі довідки.
Зібрати на виплати необхідні заяви
могли й інші держслужбовці.
Найбільше, чого не хоче зараз Володимир,
аби на звільнених чиновники заробляли політичні бали.
Не відомо, коли ми їх побачимо - гроші,
це може бути 27 червня,
як ми, типу, обіцяли
або восени, або під вибори президента чи парламенту.
Лише нещодавно полонені почали отримувати спецдомогу
від місцевих адміністрацій:
залежно від місця проживання це 5 або ж 50 тисяч гривень.
Суму в 100 тисяч колись теж обіцяють виплатити
й одразу одним переказом.